but we have already had some new figures
in the last hour from the Office of
National Statistics this is the data
looking at the number of deaths in total
in the UK there is a slight timelike to
assemble the reporting but let's get the
main points now from our economics
editor ed Conway morning ed morning and
yeah we have been looking at these
numbers they are from the Office for
National Statistics there for excess
deaths you'll remember each day we get
numbers from the government and they
have started to include numbers of
people who have died outside of hospital
more recently but these really are the
most definitive measure of how many
people have died of Kovach 19 and indeed
from all causes in England and Wales
these numbers are forming them Wales I
should say but there are numbers for
Scotland and for Northern Ireland saying
more or less the same thing and there
was some speculation as to whether the
number of total deaths people talk about
excess deaths it's a kind of statistical
term basically talking about happy
people are dying in a given week
compared with the average over the
course of the previous five years and it
gives you a sense you know if you're
trying to adjust for whether all of the
coded 19 deaths have been properly
diagnosed well some people would rather
just look at the total number of deaths
above the seasonal average and some
people thought that there might be a
chance that it might continue to
increase for the good news actually is
that it does look like excess deaths
have Peaks they were up above 22,000 in
the previous week so between that week
16 was the previous week that was the
week that started the Easter Monday and
now we have to have a week 17 which is
the week ending at the 24th of April and
it was 20 1997 people in total who died
from all causes in England and Wales
during that week that's down by 354
compared with the previous week and as I
say there will be some relief even
though that number is very high it is
far higher than anyone would like to see
it's actually pretty much double what
you would normally expect at this time
of year there'll be some relief that it
is now starting to fall that we have
those comprehensive figures from the
owner
and they're suggesting the numbers are
falling and his that the thing that's
worth just I think bearing in mind Adam
you know a lot of people who looked at
this disease and they said that in many
ways it is worse it has a higher
potential fatality rate than many
diseases probably probably any epidemic
that the UK has faced since the Spanish
Influenza at the started like have just
actually just over a century ago well
what we now know is the number of people
who have died of this is below as a
percentage as a percentage of the
population is below what we saw in the
worst weeks of the Hong Kong flu which
is the flu that happened towards the
late 60s so we are actually coming in
below that level if you're looking at
total number of excess deaths below the
levels we saw in the first week of 1970
so there will be some I think relief
that we managed to not you know that we
haven't seen numbers coming and above
what they were in that disease and many
people in the government the source of
patra balance a moment ago will say that
is due to the lockdown measures that
have been imposed as I say though some
reassurance that the numbers seem to
have peaked although it's worth pointing
out that while they certainly have
peaked in hospitals and they're coming
down what these numbers show is that a
number of deaths in care homes is still
rising and a number of deaths in private
homes is still rising so there is a bit
of a divergence there but the overall
numbers of total excess deaths now
starting to fall and will be literally
taken as some form of slight reassurance
that indeed we are now well past the
peak at Conway thank you very much
indeed for that